[Music]
but there's just been too many losses
great hold from a spoiler it's just a
great job isn't it 30 seconds again for
a one versus forty one tapping away and
taking down 25 seconds he is looking for
the straight ace clutch try and give
back in this game that would be a bit of
a miracle once again he's picked up the
palm and he wants to go upstairs make it
a bit of noise it can choke them out and
just be as noisy as possible maybe
they're gonna be looking the wrong way
but they're hiding in the corner now
it's a one-on-one makers coming in he's
just out of the bottom forest he needs
one more kill will be historic but if he
could do his brownie landing on top he's
down to 50
look guys whether you hate it or you
love it you got to admit nuke is an
essential part of counter-strike history
it may be CS goes most maligned map and
yet it gets a bad rap a lot of the time
but remember the contributions it's made
to the scene from ni PS 87 and ol and
streak to astrologist current dynasty
and we thought it was about time that
somebody gave this challenging this
unique this frankly frustrating map a
little love that's why we're gonna start
this highlight package out with the very
best clips from a site and outside move
on to be site and ramp and end things
off with some absolutely classic plays
from the 1.6 air now let's get it
started with a site an outside that's
been all ni P in the second half pissed
around one by SK and they haven't gotten
a single round after that yeah right Oh
what is that reaction get right get out
Furth
[Music]
they'll manage to escape one three now
one on three simple these last couple of
rounds has been lights out I used so
hard to stop sue she's gonna be going
down parties now oh my god
that's the bombers World War tell me
taking down every single one this
position he's looking to top up on the
sky and he's gonna do it 30 Oh what
device will be furious looking bangin it
obviously you can take a lot of positive
things from even the law is an open
position for now now won't be the force
by a good pick for Navi now sports
already achieved
goodbye Oscar thank you for playing
today simply as a fashion outside that
was brilliant and what was the decision
wait this is ridiculous okay but one vet
died from Christian but that won't be
the bomb on the radar will it pull
players out of position
ouch into the wall he won't be spotted
it gets one against flush up Olaf is
still close enough he'll rotate back oh
this is quite a nifty actually I'm not
sure he's got a better chance this is
really good from cliff he's got a better
chance of finding Olof now for free
because he thinks that outside scum
there it is perfect headshot man down as
you say Cressy jumping in through the
hut gonna spot the first world and it
goes down moving in for a little more
baiting our shots that's the right way
land will be spotted and pulse points
mark off what's happening he gets
himself a double electronic trade you
get to spray down that's insane these
are such disgusting shots I mean the
presence of mind as well for the pre
Matt this one that is dis advantageous
for them and it looks like net go guys
is doing everything they can to
capitalize on this only shroud is left
alive he has to fight he does have an m4
in his hand this is gonna be a 1 versus
5 sprays a lot of bullets not able to
connect gets to right there trying to go
for the 3rd and he gets the 3rd and oh
my god oh my god if he clutches this he
is the nuttiest player alive no way
oh man
my headphone I don't even know what that
last clip was for all you oh geez who
remember shroud at his best at csgo now
let's drop down Vince to be site and
move on to one of the most dangerous
places in the entire map Wham
quickly before trick to even go in for
this one they're gonna have to find
kills thick and fast since the first man
in it's gonna take time away land oh
there's console as well this your brains
out Rick so finds another one just an
electronic left it's great site three
electronic what are you doing
there's a quad cure for electronic
whoever finishes up the job what a nuts
play from Electronic pushing towards
Ramba drop there's no nevis whatsoever
offering itself up to them that's a
foolish way it's just open the gate for
them fortunately Chris Shay's there to
close it not briefly oh my god awful
fine more need you thinkin down just
when it looked like they had a chance
rocks over extends but Chris J just
slaps it in the face but res can't land
it get taken down and Jachin he's hurt
as well get right now let's draw us once
again punch a hole through the defense
with this spray but he he is going to be
taken away and that looks like it could
be it because electronic he's 1 P 3 how
can he do this oh one more to go though
bomb planted you will quickly apply the
pressure tapping on that one as he moves
forward through the door trying to guess
but it's gonna be made very difficult
he's he's up against device and he's
going for the hole by electronic that's
the plane RV needed to get back in
that's the kind of brains you want to
see from them position as well can't
address the fact that he's got to walk
in and catch them off rotating in and if
they've x force that opposition already
inside a control room but forest gets
caught that's gonna end the play a
little bit for an IP but that kill
coming back to MDK opens up the plant
potential watch Kenny drop down hits
exist up close and it's kept right vs
Kenny what a compromising 1v1 spotted a
ball that is unbelievable keep the dream
alive for envious you can see the crowd
erupting here it looks like they're
expecting somebody to be around this
corner there's the first it does get a
chance to reposition looking for
compete option that is ludicrous turn
around that's one of those ridiculous
things I've seen it all
oh there we go that is neato coming in
the back twice it's that bridge day all
of a sudden is flipped around once again
two versus one the world's best player
up against to the stay in the game will
be no catching C's in transition and
guardian it is a style skill they're
coming through followed off as well
still another two to go Guardian now
with the triple 1 versus support with an
AWP didn't know where you're coming from
he's gonna tap the bond once Rubino is
he tempted to go out he's gonna be
walking and Guardian turning around he
picks it up unleashed and that is gonna
be one of the most ridiculous one me
Falls I've seen in a long time they'll
do everything they can mister running
win this game on a round by round basis
until we can do at the stage as it sits
to be a clean sweep over this up before
boys defects all do what I can here but
because it'll be taken down in a few
seconds flashbang pretty decent well
that's an Isis every day what a tip
towards AC it won't smell he'll survive
six now anyone that versus 525 HP only
to work with the bomb will reach its
logical conclusion is he gonna go for
this are they still down there oh my god
oh my god oh my is the clutch master and
that is ungodly I'm sorry it's gotta go
that way north oh my brilliance so as we
saw guys there are no shortage of sick
new clips in csgo but what if we turn
back the clock back to the 1.6 era when
walls were paper-thin and you could
wallbang anybody from just about any
position
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a three-on-three limp
thank you and the bumpers get right
compasses up from the other man
Oh his tail as well as glow joins the
party crack comes down dropping triple
threat from close can you believe it
this is the MPO this is a major I say
it's a bustling honestly what exciting
it wasn't sweating gains with our party
the fire stopped my uzw or total top
budget
stir the pool at Nvidia bombshell
bootable loss value of a sign on the
downloadables this process Annika
[Music]
next up Andy hull is very useful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you dare well guys that's all she
wrote for the very best of nuke now in
case you didn't know we already gave
this treatment to counterstrikes
quintessential map that is dust2 so
check that video out if you haven't seen
it already and by the way we honestly
love doing these map based videos so if
there's one you'd like to see us do a
video on whether it be Inferno or
trained let us know in the comments
below so we can try to make it happen
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]